c'est une grande nouvelle pour toi alors
ce que j'ai retrouvé
[Musique]
le tout premier amour
sublime premier amour celui qui dure
toujours
[Musique]
j'étais au Club Med de ma naissance à
maintenant m'appelle trident
tu pourrais quand même accueillir à ton
petit frère demi-frère encore mieux je
prends moins de place je veux retrouver
mon amour d'enfance de mes 8 ans
violette je peux dormir ici alors oui je
savais je le savais ça
[Musique]
non plus tu as vu ta gueule on irait
que tu as des enfants vous retrouvez ici
une erreur que sa ville est là-bas au
Club Med déjà tu t'appelles plus Roxane
tu t'appelles violette ok je m'appelle
Jeannette voilà
non tu t'appelles violette oui ok
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un film
d'espionnage j'adore sexy heureuse
de ma vie
non pas pris dans un dentifrice
regarde bien c'est important que tu
reconnais
[Musique]
ça fait si longtemps
oui pardon c'est l'émotion de le revoir
[Musique]